so this is a live picture from our
camera on top of the red rock resort
looking across at the strip it is quiet
uh sherry's got the day off so hanging
onto the weather clicker temperatures
are dipping a little bit uh from the mid
50s some neighborhoods into the upper
40s now it's a 52 out at reed
international
let's see there's 48 for mountains edge
51 for seven hills and anthem
53 out at the lakes now earlier this
morning it was still at 61 now 58 for
downtown the strip nellis was at 60 but
it is so nice up this is great weather
for an early morning jog walk in the dog
or whatever a quickly to nevada and
beyond now even up in northern nevada
ely that 21 should feel a little more
comfortable after some single digit
early morning readings last week good
morning to cedar city your 28 mesquite
good morning to your 53 kingman at 45.
all of these temperatures are only going
to be going up for the next couple of
days before sinking back a little bit
we'll get the eight day forecast going
here in just a minute yesterday's high
72 we're going to do the same thing
today our current temperature is the low
so far that's close to normal but the
big thing you're probably going to
notice here is the sun not getting up
until 6 53 but because that's what
daylight saving time is all around the
sun staying up until 6 47 this evening
okay high pressure for sure in control
but man this is a tightly tightly wound
up area of low pressure out in the
pacific it will slowly push this high
pressure out over the next couple of
days
there was that bombogenesis we were
talking about on friday that would
really affect the folks over the eastern
one-third of the country over the
weekend it is technically still winter
time that has moved off to sea there is
another round of snow moving through the
dakotas parts of minnesota now and
northern wisconsin and maybe some
trailing snow down in extreme southern
colorado all right let's get your eight
day forecast going tomorrow the warmest
of the next eight days many
neighborhoods are going to hit 80
tomorrow officially we think we'll fall
just shy of that and then backing it
down a little bit with a mix of sun and
clouds in the meantime it will warm back
up beautiful for st patrick's day on
thursday man we got several days of
green beer to go here but as we get you
towards the weekend we'll cloud up a
little bit a ton of wind expected on
sunday which will drop high temperatures